der gemeinsamen digitalen
pressekonferenz der freistaat bayern und
der freistaat sachsen haben beschlossen
im kampf gegen die krone bandelin noch
enger zusammenzuarbeiten darüber
informieren sie heute die beiden
ministerpräsidenten dr markus söder für
bayern und michael kretschmer für
sachsen
der bayerische ministerpräsident die
kinder ja man ist sehr verehrt mattern
lieber michael schönen guten morgen nach
sachsen
wir beide beide bundesländer sind sehr
eng miteinander verbunden und beide
bundesländer arbeiten seit länger zeit
freundschaftlich zusammen jetzt ein uns
heute wieder ein weniger
freundschaftlich aber sehr notwendige
und schwierige situation wir beide sind
grants ländern ganz besonders stark
betroffen von der situation die wir mit
unserem nachbarn tschechien an
tschechien ist das land mit der höchsten
instanz in ganz europa und wir haben
beide jeweils lange außengrenze und es
ist nachvollziehbar dass durch die
infektions lagern das
infektionsgeschehen in tschechien sich
umgekehrt auch bei uns einträge ergeben
haben
deswegen haben beide länder gemeinsam
auch den antrag gestellt beim bund nicht
nur das zu mutations gebieten zu
erklären
wir sind übrigens gibt nur unsere
bundesländer die ein nachbarland als
mutations gebiet haben in anderen
bundesländern deutschland haben was
nicht und wir haben auch beide überlegen
grenzkontrollen gebeten grenzkontrollen
sind ein wichtiges instrument und hat
uns auch schon ein erster erfolg
gebracht trotzdem wir wollen einen
schritt weiter gehen
carola bewegt uns sehr diese woche wird
eine ganz entscheidende woche werden die
entscheidende weichenstellung für die
nächsten monate sein
die lage ist nicht nur wegen tschechien
es waren auch in deutschland instabil
die zahlen steigen leicht wieder in ganz
deutschland
bei uns ist es so dass während
differenziertes bild haben in bayern wir
haben eng spannendere zahlen im mittel
des landes und wir nach wie vor groß
trotz ports an der grenze gerade eben zu
tschechien
es ist ganz wichtig festzustellen dass
die mutation beginnt zu übernehmen
die moderation übernimmt und das
ergebnis ist jetzt dass wir erkennen
müssen dass wir aufpassen dass wir nicht
in eine dritte welle hineinkommen
deswegen ist ganz entscheidend dass wir
in dieser woche kluge entscheidungen
griff kluge entscheidung heißt es muss
der stimmung die stimmen
aufgenommen werden wir müssen die
richtige balance finden zwischen
vorsicht und öffnen und wird auf keinen
fall die nerven verlieren
gerade auf die politik kommt es jetzt in
dieser woche an
nicht die nerven zu verlieren und
einfach alles an allen wünschen zu
entsprechen sondern umgekehrt das ganze
in ein kluges und vorsichtiges konzept
zu machen das heißt kein öffnungs raus
sondern ein kluges abgestimmtes
ausbalanciertes öffnen mit leitplanken
und sicherheitspuffern zu ermitteln
denn das schlimmste was uns passieren
kann wäre wenn wir in zwei oder drei
wochen wieder derselben situation stehen
und eine dritte welle er völlig
unkontrolliert deswegen vorsichtige weg
mit kompass kein blindflug in die dritte
welle hinein das ist ganz entscheidend
das sind wir bayern und sachsen übrigens
auch einer meinung aber jetzt auch für
die minister über sinn -konferenz lieber
etwas vorsichtiger lieber etwas
langsamer
wir sind nicht gegen öffnungen sind fein
ausbalanciertes öffnung system aber ohne
sicherheit wird es schwierig und dabei
ist entscheidend regionale
differenzierung ja das müssen wir in
bayern machen
regionale differenzierung ja aber
umgekehrt eine einheitliche philosophie
und kein reiner wildwuchs in deutschland
der dringende appell auch nicht zahlen
bei incidents die entscheidend sind
ständig zu verändern oder neu bewerten
jeden tag eine neue zahl wie besitzt von
olaf scholz bürgern von distanzen muss
still nachvollziehbar sein sonst geht
auch die legitimation bei der
bevölkerung verloren wenn der eindruck
entsteht wie ändern ständig die
entsprechenden grenzen und die instanzen
die wir da haben wir brauchen also
öffnungen auf der einen seite auf der
anderen seite mit schutzkonzepte des
sicherheitspuffers in ffb zwei masken
ein schnelltest konzept von dem wir
allerdings wissen müssen wann und wie
und die nachweisbar ist es um die
verlässlich ist ist weit ist sind eine
echte hoffnungs chance aber schnell
testzentrum keine schnell waffe die
bereits ab nächster woche umfangreich
zur verfügung steht deswegen der
dringende appell an den bund jetzt bis
mittwoch das klar vorzulegen
besitz unsere situation in dem zusammen
beide länder stellen fest dass die
hotspots eine große herausforderung sind
in der region bemühen sich beide die
landkreise die landräte enorm um eine
verbesserung zu weich und jeweiligen
länder sachsen aber auch bayern
unterstützen dies mit sehr strengen
maßnahmen aber auch mithilfe
wir stellen aber fest dass wir es noch
verbessern müssen
wir müssen das herz europas gerade im
moment es ist genau das herz europas
dieses dreiecks leidet ganz besonders
unter corona und deswegen müssen wir
diesen herz eine besondere
unterstützungsleistung geben müssen die
pumpleistung sozusagen verbessern
dessen haben wir beide uns entschieden
und idee kam von michael kretschmer sagt
das ausdrücklich er mich angerufen hat
das können wir noch zusammen tun
deswegen danke auch dir ganz persönlich
für diesen impuls ich halte ihn für
dringend notwendig wir machen einen
engen austausch enger austausch heißt ja
mist schon beim thema der
grenzkontrollen gemeinschaftlich
abgestimmt wir wollen ein einheitliches
lagebild haben einen ständigen austausch
einen abgleich auch machen was das
testen betrifft wo getestet wird wie
getestet wird wie sequenzierungen
beispielsweise auch dass die überall
stattfinden müssen denn wir brauchen ein
exaktes bild über die mutations
geschwindigkeit und die mutations
ausbreitung die dort stattfindet also
haben wir einen zehn-punkte-plan all
diese arbeiten miteinander definiert um
das zu verbessern
für bayern sage ich noch dazu wollen wir
weiter die hotspots auch ganz bewusst
stärken indem wir zwei bereiche dort
verstärken logistisch mehr impfstoff
zusätzlich nach in die landkreise geben
mehr impfstoff insbesondere aus dem
astra zenica bereich der ja noch nicht
in der gamestar wie alles andere mehr
impfstoff weiter in die grenzregion und
auch mehr schnelltests wir wünschen uns
übrigens auch und es wäre ganz wichtig
dass entweder von europa vom bund noch
einmal eine zusätzliche unterstützung
bei der impfstoff lieferung kommt für
hotspot regionen
warum man kann in hotspots später oder
gar nicht öffnen
dafür muss man schneller immunisieren
also eine antwort auf hotspots ist doch
dass man nicht die gleichen das gleiche
öffnungs regime haben kann wie soll man
bei uns in münchen oder du hast glaube
ich ein
stress das sehr niedrige zahl das ist
vergleichbar aber deswegen musste ein
anders sie haben aber für die strategie
kann man einfach seinem ist halt warten
bis irgendwann sondern der wer schneller
immunisieren dann ist später öffnen auch
an der stelle gut vertretbar und wir
haben uns also mit dem was wir extra für
unsere leute tut und leben was wir uns
vom bund noch zusätzlich gut
unterstützen könnten mit zusätzlichen
impfstoff jetzt auch in den nächsten
tagen wochen haben wir uns auch
entschieden jetzt nicht nur uns
abzusichern sondern wir nehmen diese
herzfunktion war ist ein herz dann aus
drei kann man hätte ich jetzt beinahe
exakt sachsen bayern und tschechien und
deswegen helfen wir auch unseren
partnern in tschechien zum einen mit dem
angebot der betten also eher
krankenhausbetten weil die situation
sich bei uns entlastet hat zum zweiten
werden wir auch schnelltests liefern und
auch impfstoff insgesamt an die
tschechin und ist wichtig was da beim
impfstoff ist und warum das auch machbar
ist weil es sich um die tschechin wird
diesen impfstoff gerne nehmen um die
hochrisiko gebiet jetzt impfen die
pendler vor allen dingen das heißt wir
werden unsere beiderseitigen entwicklung
noch einmal stärken indem auch gerade
tschechische pendler dort geben mit dem
impfstoff geimpft werden können und
damit erreichen wir nicht nur den schutz
von tschechien sondern ganz besonders
auch bei uns zusammenfassend gesagt am
corona wird uns die nächsten monate
weiter beschäftigen darüber darf sich
keiner täuschen
wir müssen jetzt wirklich sehr klug
abwägen was wir tun
ich kenne die stimmungslage und ich
möchte auch ehrlicher weiß dass wir so
so so frei wie möglich leben können wir
werden ein stück weit auch freiheit
natürlich den menschen zurückgeben das
selbstverständlich in den rahmen
eröffnung mit freiheit geht aber auch
verantwortung einher und zwar doppelt
für den einzelnen wir diese freiheit
warnend aber unsere verantwortung ist
auch das ganze so zu machen dass wir
nicht in absehbarer zeit einfach wieder
vor derselben entwicklung stehen und
begleitet werden muss das mit mehr
impfen und mehr testen
das ganze aber in einem konzept dass das
ganze nicht chaotisch stattfindet und
deswegen letzter satz nochmal zum impfen
auch zu meinem ansatz gestern und er
mich ja wir haben beide den gleichen
ansatz muss man sagen
wir glauben auch übrigens das ist
spätestens dann wenn jetzt massiv mehr
impfstoff kommt es dringend notwendig
ist
das impfkonzept komplett zu überarbeiten
wirklich warum es wird sonst nur eine
art mangelverwaltung werden also mit
einem überbürokratisiert ins system
kommen wir nicht weiter deswegen
spätestens april also spätestens wenn
der ganz große anteil vom impfstoff
kommt muss jede dose impfstoff geimpft
werden wo es nur geht
und deswegen das system verändern
komplett über als und neben den
impfzentren über die ärzte das heißt
über hausärzte über betriebsärzte also
hausärzte können übrigens am besten
entscheiden wer chronisch krank ist
diese informationen liegen uns gar nicht
so vor also kann man das ganze dann über
die entsprechenden hausärzte machen über
betriebsärzte dort können ganze gebiet
rebic im stand übrigens auch deren
familien und natürlich auch über schul
erste was ich sehr sinnvoll halte um
zumindest bei den älteren schülern wurde
im stoff empfohlen ist das ganze zu
machen es führt übrigens dazu dass aus
der priorisierung der rechtlich fixierte
eine empfehlung werden kann
die dann noch angewandt wird nur so
können wir den dramatischen rückstand in
deutschland beim impfen hat aufhören wir
müssen aufholen und wir müssen besser
werden
unter beide länder sind sowohl in der
bewertung der tschechischen situation
und dem hilfsangebot an tschechien aber
auch dass sicherheitslage für uns als
auch für den mittwoch ziemlich einig und
das ist glaube ich schon mal auch ein
gutes signal für diese woche die wehre
mich ja noch mal danke für die wie immer
exzellente zusammenarbeit zwischen
bayern und sachsen ist jetzt meine
zukunft nachfolger vielen dank dank
ministerpräsident nicht mehr kriegt man
bitte in vielen dank und auch ein
herzliches grüß gott nach bayern meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir
haben begonnen mit zu einem kleinen
lagebild wie ist die situation an der
bayerisch sächsischen begrenze und in
der region und man sieht sehr deutlich
eine ganz besondere betroffenheit die
wir eben auch spüren regionen mit einer
instanz von 500 800 900 aber eben auch
von 1008
100 und jetzt kann man wenn man ein
bisschen die situation in deutschland
über die vergangenen monate gesehen hat
vielleicht sich ausmalen wie dramatisch
muss es sein wenn über einen so langen
zeitraum in einem landkreis in einer
region eine instanz über 1000 vorhanden
ist
deswegen war das für uns mag es so
wieder an mich und wir haben auch einen
kollegen rammel oder zu gewonnen
eine selbstverständlichkeit zu fragen in
der tschechischen republik welche form
der unterstützung wäre jetzt angebracht
womit können wir helfen wir haben
festgestellt am samstag dass eine
impfkampagne in der grenzregion nicht
stattfinden könnte
weil die tschechische republik zu wenig
impfstoff geliefert bekommen hat es ist
immer leicht wenn man etwas im überfluss
hat sein abzugeben
das ist derzeit auch in deutschland
nicht der fall aber es ist wichtig und
es hilft ich bin sehr dankbar
markus söder und auch bodo ramelow es
zeigt glaube ich eine ganz besondere
haltung und auch den wunsch auch wenn
wir hier so in einer großen
schwierigkeit sind dass man sich nicht
vergisst sondern dass man für einander
da ist diese besonders wohnen instanzen
führen dazu dass wir einen großen
eintrag haben in deutschland und
deswegen war es unvermeidlich die
grenzen jetzt zu schließen wenn ich will
das auch sagen weil ich die diskussion
an anderen stellen gerade im saarland
verfolge eine grenzschließung oder ein
grenzregime ohne kontrollen ist absolut
wirkungslos macht den menschen etwas vor
die auch diese erfahrung haben wir
gemacht wir haben in stunden an einigen
kleinen grenzübergängen 40 proben
gemacht davon die ungeheuerliche zahl
von 16 die positiv war oft maß die
britische mutation es blieb uns nichts
anderes übrig und trotzdem sehen wir
gerade jetzt auch im vogtland in der
region tirschenreuth hof diesen sehr
sehr großen eintrag und deswegen die
gemeinsame überlegung was kann man tun
damit dort trotzdem
dinge weiter gehen weiterhin möglich
sind das test regime das angebot für die
unternehmen sich qualifizieren zu lassen
dort tests für die mitarbeiter
anzubieten
wir haben im vogtland jetzt begonnen
kostenlos zu testen ist am wochenende
auch sehr gut angenommen
der landrat hat meine ausdrückliche
unterstützung dass er für die dinge die
jetzt im gesellschaftlichen bereich und
wirtschaftlichen bereich möglich sind
eine negativen corona tipps zur
voraussetzung gemacht wir müssen die
zahlen senken wir sehen in dieser region
anders als in anderen im freistaat
sachsen bereits wieder eine prognose die
steigend ist für die krankenhäuser und
deswegen bin ich froh darüber dass wir
hier ein gemeinsames vorgehen haben zu
dem gemeinsamen vorgehen gehört auch die
feststellung und das ist etwas was auch
andere bundesländer mit uns teilen dass
man vermutlich der situation mit den
jetzigen werkzeugen alleine nicht herr
wird sondern dass wir ein besonderes ihm
im frieden brauchen für diese regionen
für diese hotspots damit die zahlen doch
zurück gehen damit wir keine
überforderung der krankenhäuser haben
dass wir vor allen dingen aber keine
weitere verbreitung in das land in
andere regionen in haben und wer sich
die karte anschaut der sieht ja genau
diesen effekt ist weitertragen system
fundieren in die verschiedenen regionen
das müssen wir verhindern dass muss bei
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am
mittwoch ein thema sein das neben den
kriterien der ständigen impfkommission
weitere kriterien dazu kommen könnt mein
wunsch wäre dass wir sehr schnell dazu
kommen in dieser besonders betroffenen
region des vogtlands angebote zu machen
für alle erwachsenen über 18 jahre das
ist aus meiner sicht eine möglichkeit
der hier tatsächlich die die ausbreitung
zu verhindern
markus söder hat das große angesprochen
und ich finde in der tat wir haben jetzt
die chance dass
modell was wir bei unserem nachbarn
sehen sei es in österreich oder der
tschechischen republik oder auch in
frankreich zu verhindern dass wir in
eine wellenbewegung kommen öffnen
schließen schließen öffnet ein ständiges
hin und her das kann niemand wollen und
deswegen müsst muss jeder öffnungs
schritt der jetzt passiert begleitet
werden abgesichert werden mit
schnelltest es bleibt uns gar nichts
anderes übrig wir haben das doch alle
miteinander gesehen
seit wochen sind die instanz in
deutschland mit diesem lockdown und seit
zehn tagen haben wir eine veränderung
eine veränderung die aus meiner sicht
aus zwei punkten her kommt einmal eine
verhaltensänderung der bevölkerung
kleine verhaltensänderungen sorgten für
mehr mobilität mehr kontakte und damit
sofort in einer zeitverzögerung von zehn
tagen für auch deutlich mehr infektionen
und wir haben diese kritische mutation
markus söder hat es angesprochen die
immer mehr auf der vor auf dem vormarsch
ist die die ursprüngliche variante
abgelöst die um ein drittel bis 50%
ansteckender ist und in dieser zeit der
steigenden infektionen kann doch jetzt
keine große lockerung erfolgen es ist
doch vollkommen klar dass das dass es
falsch ist es deswegen kann es am
mittwoch nur um kleine schritte gehen
und um eine test strategie die klar
schafft klar sagt in welchen bereichen
wie viel kapazität in der zukunft zu
handen ist und dann müssen wir die
lockerungsschritte im bereich der kultur
die wir hoffentlich bald sehen des
sports der wirtschaft der bildung ganz
klar an dieses test konzept an
schnelltest binden wir haben aus meiner
sicht können wir keine gewissheit haben
dass uns das gelingt dass das was jetzt
gerade in der tschechischen republik
passiert dass diese unglaubliche
mutation so einen eine verheerende
wirkung entfaltet wir haben heute in
sachsen unter zehn prozent der
unternehmen die kurzarbeit angemeldet
haben und wir hatten im vergangenen jahr
ist zu einem drittel
unser ziel muss doch
dass diese zahl weiter zurückgeht dass
die menschen die in kurzarbeit sind die
zu hause sitzen weiter zurückgehen das
meer wieder möglich ist das wird uns
aber nur gelingen wenn wir das nicht
blind tun sondern wissen wir brauchen
aus der aus dem system der pauschalen
kontakt vermeidung müssen wir kommen in
ein system der sicheren kontakte das
geht nur mit so einem schnelltest
konzept aus meiner sicht das haben wir
an vielen stellen gesehen das brauchen
wir jetzt für ganz deutschland
vielen dank willkommen zu den fragen der
journalisten
den anfang macht eva eismann vom
bayerischen rundfunk
von jürgen umlauft frankenpost der neue
tag entschuldigung ich mal hier ich habe
es nicht geschafft die stummschaltung
aufzuheben
auch nach mehreren monaten im lotto
also da zwei fragen hätte ich ansieht
wenn sie sagen herr kretschmann hat es
ja angesprochen es ist immer leicht
sachen herzugeben oder großzügig mit
sachen umzugehen
die mal im überfluss hat das ist ja
jetzt mit dem impfstoff nicht der fall
uns erreichen immer wieder fragen von
höheren von zuschauern die sagen aber
wir sind hochrisikopatienten wir
brauchen dringend die impfung und so
weiter wie schätzen sie das ein wie
verstehen dass die menschen wenn sie
sagen einen teil von dem wenigen das wir
haben geben wir jetzt tatsächlich nach
tschechien
wie schätzen sie das ein die andere
frage ist herr kretschmer sie haben
gesagt man muss viel testen mann soll
von einem system der der kontakt
beschränkungen zu den sicheren kontakten
kommen
das heißt sie könnten sich vorstellen da
zu lockern würde das bedeuten vielleicht
auch in richtung schulen könnte man sich
lockerungen vorstellen
vielen dank ja wir sind ja jetzt mit den
schulen schon haben wir begonnen
vorsichtig und wir sehen dass was auch
zu erwarten war wenn die institute zu
hoch ist haben sie den eintrag überall
in die schulen in die freiwillige
feuerwehr in die altenheime überall hin
das ist ja diese dramatische situation
und um das abzusichern wäre eben werden
schnelltests die möglichkeit über die
auch einmal ganz deutlich sagen der eine
oder andere wirft dann ein ja viele
tests bedeuten danach eine noch höhere
instanz und man sagen nein viele tests
bedeuten dass man das dunkelfeld sieht
und diejenigen die infiziert sind die
für andere anstecken sind man schnell
mal 14 tage drei wochen zu hause hat
aber damit diese welle jeden tag aufs
neue bricht und das ist für die schule
eine möglichkeit ich sehe sie nicht
jetzt gleich morgen aber ich sehe sie in
wirklich greifbare absehbarer zeit und
deswegen wollen wir dieses modell auch
ergreifen
wir haben es jetzt für friseure
vorgeschrieben in ganz sachsen wenn sie
zur arbeit gehen einmal die woche wir
haben im vogtland die situation dass
alle sich testen müssen weil wir es dort
auch kostenlos zur verfügung
es ist natürlich ganz klar eine frage
erstens des preises und zweitens auch
der praktikabilität also diese schnell
dass die wir kennen mit diesen langen
stäbchen werden dafür nicht geeignet
seien
von daher auch da ganz in ruhe wir
werden jetzt in den nächsten wenigen
wochen auch so viel mehr an
technologischen entwicklungen haben
dinge die einfach sind die praktikabel
sind die man auch selber machen kann die
vom preis sehr günstig sind die
verfügbar sind
darauf müssen wir setzen es ist ein
statement gewesen ähnliche markus söder
gegen dieses jetzt unkontrollierte
nerven verlieren
schnell schnell öffnen weil wir wissen
dass ein großer teil der bevölkerung
sich das wünscht aber ich bin der
meinung wenn man weiß was richtig ist
muss man dabei bleiben dass sich am ende
heraus auch dann so raus stellt neben
schließe ich mich an noch zu dem punkt
zwei ergänzungen ist redet jeder
natürlich über die wichtigen
wirtschaftsbereichen handel und und auch
gastronomie wird will ich gesprochen wir
werden für mittwoch zeitachsen
definieren müssen beispielsweise bis
ostern
dass man mal sieht aber es bestimmen
immer sozusagen das datum bestimmt nicht
den weg sondern die daten also wir sind
die daten man kann nicht einfach öffnen
ohne diese entsprechenden daten zu sehen
die wir haben und es kann regional
differenziert sein klar oder 35 sind bei
uns in münchen da wird auf jeden fall
was gehen müssen geht gar nicht anders
aber dort wo die zahlen sehr hoch sind
da muss man dann immer einen anderen weg
finden und es ist wichtig dass wir neben
den wirtschaftsbereich immer die schule
auf gleicher augenhöhe sehen also uns
beiden ist die schule sehr sehr wichtig
das muss man wirklich sagen weil da geht
es um kinder und jugendliche und es sind
bei mindestens so viele leute betroffen
wie in anderen anderen bereichen zudem
ist das was wir machen ist ja wenn man
ehrlich ist von der menge her
symbolische maßnahme es ist nicht so
dass das jetzt der größenordnung ist die
jetzt dass uns unsere impfkonzept da nur
annähernd durcheinander bringt aber es
ist eine symbolische maßnahme dass
solidarität
der grenzregion und zum zweiten ist es
schon eine hilfreiche maßnahme denn die
wahrheit ist doch wir brauchen natürlich
auch die tschechischen pendler weil wir
in der krankenhausversorgung in der
medizin schnappen vielen wirklich
wirtschaftlichen bereichen gerade auch
die hervorragende arbeit die dort
geleistet wird der tschechischen pendler
schätzen wenn die tschechischen pendler
geimpft werden
dann nützt uns das auch bei uns sehr
stark weil 1 muss es ja muss ja sehen in
den hotspots besteht immer die gefahr
der verbreitung als ein beispiel wie gc
und würden in einigen bereichen öffnen
nehmen wir an den handel oder
handelskonzepte weil die inzidenz ist
sehr niedrig sind dann besteht natürlich
die herausforderung das möglicherweise
in beutel aus deinen grenzland lassen
danach touristen fahren oder bei uns
nach münchen um einzukaufen
sonst gibt es da zwar arbeite
schutzkonzepte weil für alles gibt es
ein schutzkonzept aber trotzdem gibt es
ja mobilität denkbare mobilität und vor
dem hintergrund nützt es uns wenn wir
dort wo wir weniger öffnen können
mehr immunisieren und das gilt für dies
und jenseits der grenze ist das eine und
das zweite was ihr noch mal sagen sich
zudem impfen
also wir müssen jetzt mehr tempo machen
im grunde genommen müsste man astra
zenica so schnell wie möglich für alle
zur verfügung stellen und nicht erst
irgendwo in vier oder sechs wochen und
jeder neue impfstoff der kommt der muss
so schnell wie möglich in ein system
abgegeben werden dass eine schnelle
führung von war ich würde astra ziehen
gerade gab es in deiner meinung
auch sofort über die hausärzte
weitergeben das was jetzt mehr kommt in
den nächsten tagen wochen weil die
hausärzte übrigens die chronisch kranken
noch selber kennen ist nämlich ein
unterschied ob man sich anmeldet ist
chronisch kranke oder ob er auch weiß
und die besten des wissens in die haus
setze jetzt zwei dinge schnell
verdampfen was jetzt geht keine
impfdosen darf in deutschland länger
liegen bleiben
es ist aus meiner sicht falsch zweitens
wir brauchen jetzt schnell diese
veränderung der der verordnung in berlin
die dem zugrunde liegt weil wir dürfen
es hier nicht machen die verordnung muss
geändert werden dass ihm danach
hausärzte betriebsärzte ich würde immer
noch für schul ärzte plädieren weil
macht gerade die älteren schüler auch
noch hervorragend impfen könnte würde
übrigens im hinblick auf abitur
und ähnliche fragen auch ein hohes maß
an sicherheit bringen wenn wir die
älteren klassen alle geimpft haben und
deswegen so schnell wie möglich die
bereiche machen und das was mit
tschechien ist wissen sie ich sage das
auch so wir müssen dieses europa auch
zusammenhalten im moment der müsste es
ja zusammenhalten und deswegen helfen
wir mit patientenbetten deswegen helfen
wir mit schnelltests und wir helfen auch
mit einem zugegebenermaßen nicht sehr
großen mengen an impfstoff aber das ist
auch eine frage der geste die
dahintersteht und jede dieser einzelne
impfdosen und jetzt im tschechischen
grenzraum dann verimpft werden kann und
es machen drei länder drei bundesländer
stellen da im stoße führen die sind
nicht so viele die wir drei länder
zusammen nehmen machen auch da die
initiative von michael habe ich dann
sofort begrüßt weil ist nützt uns aber
auch wieder weil jeder der geimpft es
gibt uns auch in unseren grenzen ein
stück weit mehr sicherheit wir werden
insgesamt jeweils drei fragen aus beiden
ländern zu lassen können das nächstes
ist die frage aus sachsen von tino
moritz frey presse hallo
denn zu verstehen ich hatte mich
eigentlich gar nicht gemeldet würde aber
die gelegenheit nutzen um nachzufragen
nach den impfstoff von gestern noch mal
herr söder ist es wirklich
ausschließlich an trends penta gedacht
die 15.000 dosen oder sollte es auch um
vorrangig um risikogruppen in tschechien
gehen
vielen dank wir sind ja mit der
tschechischen regierung im gespräch und
er wird in den grenzregionen eingesetzt
ich habe auch die drei landkreise aber
ich habe es jetzt nicht da
das haben wir aber gar nicht jetzt so
großartig gesagt sondern das war auch
von der tschechischen regierung
vollkommen klar dass das passieren
sollte und es war auch für diese region
gedacht und diese kam impfkampagne die
nicht stattfinden können hätten wir die
hilfe nicht angeboten und dass er noch
mal sagen es ist auch die frage wartet
man bis man gebeten wird oder fragt man
mal nach und das haben wir gemacht ich
finde es richtig und habe mich sehr
gefreut dass wir da so schnell und
unkompliziert was machen konnten
man sieht auch
an der reaktion der tschechischen seite
wie sehr not sie sind die haben also
innerhalb von stunden das alles
organisiert und werden das heute in
leipzig abholen die menge und dann
teilen wir uns danach wieder auf dann
kommen wir zur nächsten frage aus bayern
jürgen umlauft frankenpost der neue tag
und dann schon zum vorjahr sachsen wäre
da nichts roland herold
ja meine frage geht an beide
ministerpräsidenten in den in der
bayerischen tschechischen grenzregion
wird mir immer wieder dass man in
tschechien für relativ wenig geld
negative kronast kaufen kann
haben sie dazu erkenntnisse und wie
wollen sie da gegebenenfalls reagieren
und dann herrn söder noch die nachfrage
ist haben angekündigt dass in den grands
landkreisen mehr impfstoff jetzt
ankommen soll geht es über die 1000
bussen die letzte woche bereits
angekündigten uns hinaus danke weitere
im jahr deutlich nachzulegen
weil normal wenn die konzeption jetzt ja
so weitergeht dass wir wir können den
grenzland leisten nicht die gleichen
öffnungszeiten machen die wir woanders
haben bei niedrigen inzidenz das ist
nicht vertretbar aber kann die einzige
antwort im dorf seiten und auch
perspektive schneller immunisieren
schneller immunisieren dort wo weniger
geöffnet werden kann ist mein eindruck
auch wir haben die mit dem
instrumentenkasten arbeiten wir jetzt
eine ganze weile schon und sehen dass er
uns in diesen hot spot regionen nur bis
zum gewissen punkt bringt das aber
unbefriedigend und deswegen ist das
impfen eine möglichkeit dazu brauchen
wir aber eine veränderung die wollen wir
jetzt in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erreichen
und dann kann man auch schneller
arbeiten und vor allen dingen eben doch
die leute die jetzt hier das thema sind
sind ja in aller regel noch arbeiten
arbeitsbereich arbeits pendler die dafür
sorgen dass da die verbreitung offenbar
weiter stattfindet und was sie sagen mit
diesen gefälschten zettel
ich halte das nicht für ausgeschlossen
können das nicht genau kontrollieren
deswegen ist auch unsere strategie jetzt
mehr dass die tests in der auf der
deutschen seite stattfinden natürlich
die einreise wenn das denn möglich ist
für die arbeitsplätze in der zukunft
immer nur mit negativen tests aber dann
finden die tests hier statt dabei sind
wir gerade dabei das zu organisieren in
den krankenhäusern pflegeeinrichtungen
ist es ja schon zu weihnachten für alle
24 stunden aktuell und das muss dann in
dem arbeitsbereich
ehrlicherweise passieren für viele auch
für bayern heißt wieder entschuldigung
wir haben ja bereits diese ganzen tests
dienten wie sie wissen ich finde es auch
gut dass jetzt heute in deutschland die
sich der trend durchsetzt dass kostenlos
viel testen notwendig ist erinnern sich
herum laufen dass wir da er mehr haufen
ärger hatten in der frage
und deswegen ist es für uns gut aber
natürlich das erste ist immer die tests
an der grenze also die der decke der
nachweis der tests die hinweise die sie
sind habe ich jetzt selber noch nicht
gehört aber die wird sicherlich im
polizeilichen umfeld auch mit der
bundespolizei noch mal gesprochen
danke für den hinweis um zu sehen welche
tests sind es dann das können sie nicht
alles 1000 prozentig ausschließen aber
wir haben umgekehrt ja auch sowohl
pendelt quarantäne als auch wöchentliche
test richten sogar mehrmals in einigen
bereichen sodass das test verschieben da
weiter absolut hoch ist also das ist ja
das was das entscheiden ist ein extrem
engmaschiges test konzept plus
grenzkontrolle und wir machen jetzt so
dass wir sogar noch bestimmte mobile
test karawanen haben die auch in bezug
auf neben den normalen zentren
zusätzlich kommen wird also wir testen
was geht was geht um so das ganze unter
kontrolle zu behalten
roland herold bitte von der leipziger
volkszeitung ja ich habe zwei fragen
erstens gibt es konkrete absprachen mit
der regierung in tschechien
möglicherweise weiteren impfstoff zu
liefern über diese 5000 dosen hinaus und
zweitens könnten sie noch etwas aus
diesen zehn punkte plan präzisieren
es gibt keine weiteren absprachen jetzt
ist vor allen dingen jetzt dann
irgendwie ja auch die die möglichkeiten
der bundesländer sind begrenzt
europäisch wird versucht eine ganze
menge auch zu tun
wahrscheinlich so dass tschechien nicht
nur in europa sondern weltweit
mit dieser instanz an der absoluten
spitze steht und ich will soll man sagen
wir erleben in deutschland die
möglichkeit auch die situation in den
betrieben
man kann sich vielleicht ein bisschen
rein denken dass ein land was diese
wirtschaftliche kraft nicht hat was
diese frage kurz regel kurzarbeitergeld
lohnfortzahlung alles nicht kennt oder
nur einen geringeren umfeld dass dort
die situation auch ganz anders ist in
der bevölkerung
dann lassen sie was diese zehn punkte
angeht beruhen sie eben auf unseren
erfahrungen wenn sie auf der anderen
seite eine so große betroffenheit haben
und in einigen punkten eben auch dann
nicht die kraft so ähnlichen wir in
deutschland handeln würden die situation
zu klären mit quarantäne mit glock
daumen und ähnlichen dann muss man so
einem system wie grenzkontrollen kommen
und wenn da niemand steht und
kontrolliert ist das alles muss ich es
ist alles platt segen
das ist ein ganz zentraler punkt dann
die frage der der test konzepte die
hotspot regelungen
das sind punkte wir haben sequenzierung
damit wir wirklich ein gutes bild haben
was ist das jetzt ist dass die mutation
oder andere punkte und es beruht
natürlich auch auf unseren erfahrungen
aus dem november dezember wo wir auch
gefragt haben ist das was wir da erlebt
haben im erzgebirge
zufall oder ist es möglicherweise auch
sehr sehr starke eintrag und
möglicherweise auch eine form von
rotation wir können das rückblickend
nicht beantworten mehr
aber wir wollen natürlich in so eine
situation jetzt nicht noch einmal kommen
deswegen aufklären testen impfen wo
immer es geht wie sie mich wie man
dann kommen wir zum finalen durchgang
ist doch trost und thilo alexe den
anfang macht christoph trost dpa
dann ist ins bayern franken bei den
ministerpräsidenten
also herr kretschmer diskussionsphase
jahr vor der pk schon etwas instanzen
gehen auseinander
nicht nur innerhalb des bundes sondern
auch innerhalb einzelner länder die
länder gehen schon längst
unterschiedlichen eröffnungs schritte
ist am mittwoch aus heutiger sicht
überhaupt noch so was wie ein
einheitlicher rahmen möglich oder droht
da sozusagen scheitern der mpk dann auch
die in diesem punkt kommt die zweite
frage beginnt vielleicht damit ihnen
herr kretschmer sie hatten am wochenende
in der faz ängstlich nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen reden wir mal ende des
sommers darüber haben sie gesagt könnten
sie da ein bisschen konkreter werden
noch bitte und was sagen sie zum thema
im licht die frage ist ja kommt nicht
irgendwann automatisch eine impfpflicht
sozusagen durch die hintertür weil nicht
geimpften viele dinge verwehrt bleiben
werden dankeschön
willst du dich schöne frage zuerst
beantworten ja dass mein zitat was ich
im mai des vergangenen jahres jemand was
dann im internet so neben dieser aussage
gestellt wird nach wie vor seine
richtigkeit hat es wird keinen zwang
geben
und jemand der nicht geimpft ist wird
auch seine grundrechte nicht verlieren
das wäre ja noch schöner
die kollegen von der faz am sonntag
haben wann das ist ein guter anleihe
genommen
die habe nämlich nach der frage der
masern gefragt wo eine viel geringere
anzahl von fällen auf einmal zu einer
solchen diskussion und einer
entscheidung geführt hat
ich habe das ganz bewusst so gesagt wir
haben jetzt nicht mal genügend impfstoff
und jedem zu impfen
der jetzt gerade geimpft werden will
deswegen kann man diese frage jetzt
nicht beantworten
sie wird sie stellen weil sie die
menschen auch umtreibt über die frage
welche kosten hatten wir eigentlich mit
dieser pandemie und wollen wir auch nur
im ansatz das risiko eingehen dass uns
so etwas noch mal passiert das ist
übrigens bei den masern auch so da
wusste jeder wiefern lernt diese
krankheit ist sie wird vor dem
hintergrund gestellt werden und
beantwortet werden müssen welche
erfahrungen mit dem impfstoff hat bei
den masern ganz klar eine sehr hohe
verträglichkeit eine sehr hohe
schutzfunktion
ein großer teil über großer teil der
deutschen ist geimpft deswegen auch eine
große akzeptanz
das haben wir jetzt gerade bei den
gronauer impfstoff noch nicht deswegen
kann man diese frage jetzt auch nicht
beantworten aber sie wird im oktober
november ganz anders sie stellen wenn
die deutschen dann wissen welchen
schutzfaktor man hat wie verträglich das
ganze gewesen ist und von daher würde
ich sagen eine gewisse gelassenheit auch
bei diesem thema und es kommt alles früh
genug immer mit der ruhe jetzt geht es
darum dass alle die wirklich geimpft
werden wollen auf die möglichkeit dazu
haben aber man darf in dieser situation
wie ich finde
nicht zu schnell nie sagen es gibt hier
wenig gewissheiten und es braucht viel
umsicht und es gibt nach dem was wir
alleine jetzt schon das ist jetzt ein
jahr her waren vor einem jahr bei der
kabinettssitzung mit der bayerischen
staatsregierung in münchen
und wir haben eine staatsregierung mit
markus söder als die aus sächsischer
sicht unglaublich sensibel für das thema
corona war die sehr vorausschauend
vorsichtig gewesen ist mit uns darüber
gesprochen hat was man jetzt alles
machen sollten so richtig haben wir das
damals noch gar nicht gesehen weil es in
sachsen diese carola fälle nicht gab
auf der rückfahrt haben wir dann die
buchmesse in leipzig abgesagt und danach
haben wir die geschichte erlebt und vor
dem hintergrund was wir jetzt gerade
alles erlebt haben wie verheerend das
ist stellt sich natürlich diese frage
wie setzt man es durch wie schaffen wir
es dass durch die segensreichen
impfstoff so eine pandemie und ein
weiterer ausbruch in der zukunft uns
erspart bleibt
zwei antworten die eine ist nochmal zum
impfen also ich glaube das wichtigste
ist jetzt dass jeder ein angebot bekommt
der sich impfen lassen will
im moment erleben werde er die situation
dass ich viele impfen lassen wollen und
keine chance angeblich zu werden die es
ist absolut richtig zu sagen dass
zunächst einmal die wohlhabenden gruppen
und die besonders belasteten in den
alten und pflegeheimen geimpft werden
sollen das glaube ich klappt jetzt sehr
gut dass im wald durch aber mit als weib
impfung
das ergebnis könnte sein dass wir das
jetzt auch schon merken wir brauchen
nicht nur die alten- und pflegeheime das
muss nicht nur für chronische kranke
sondern der breite stattfinden es ist
auch ganz wichtig dass wir bald
impfstoffe haben für kinder und
jugendliche denn dort finden die größten
sozialen belastung statt
ob sich leute in unserem alter mal
weniger treffen können ist auch schon
schwierig aber für kinder hat es
langfristige folgen also muss auch dies
erhöht werden
deswegen ist glaube ich das
entscheidende jetzt so schnell wie
möglich so viel impfstoff wie möglich
weiter zu akquirieren
ich halte es nach wie vor für sinnvoll
dass wir auch die zulassungsverfahren
beschleunigen
auf europäischer ebene es ist ja so dass
im endeffekt alles zugelassen wird was
woanders auch zugelassen wird nur viel
später also ich bin sehr für das sichere
verfahren aber wenn das ergebnis immer
das gleiche
bloß wird europa viel später dran sind
dann verlieren wir im geschwindigkeit
und der verlust von imf geschwindigkeit
ist die verzögerung von freiheit und ist
die geringere chance vom
wirtschaftlichen erfolg
es wird uns wären viele dinge noch
einholen wirtschaftlich das jahr weil
wir später geimpft haben als andere
dass sie ist es dringend notwendig dass
zu erhöhen
jedem muss ein angebot gemacht werden er
will und zweitens wer sich nicht impfen
lassen will auf dauer der musst du deine
pflicht bekommen es bin ich glaube ich
wieder mit er sagte ich jetzt für eher
unwahrscheinlich aber ich oder ich würde
es nicht machen
aber was klar ist es muss natürlich dann
am ende auch eine andere form von von
von wahrnehmung geben es ist doch ganz
klar wenn sich jemand nicht impfen
lassen will
und jemand anderes im quartier dass sich
impfen lässt dann die entsprechenden
nachteile in kauf nehmen es ist es kann
der gar nicht auf dauer gerecht sein
gerecht bedeutet wer sich impfen lässt
schützt sich und andere sich zu impfen
schützt sich und andere war dann auch
keine verbreitung hat und daraus folgt
aber auch dass dann das leben so weit
ist normalisiert werden muss für jemand
der geimpft ist und ab einer bestimmten
zahl von giften
deswegen finde ich auch der impfausweis
impfpässe absolut sinnvoll nicht nur auf
europäischer ebene beim reisen sondern
dann auf dauer auch natürlich für das
alltagsleben so dazu muss aber mehr
geimpft werden und es muss breiter
geimpft werden
im moment ist dieses ganze system was
wir haben natürlich noch ein system das
sich am mangel orientiert und nicht an
der masse das jetzige system ist ein
mangel im system und kann masse ins
system und wir müssen jetzt wenn die
nächsten tage und jetzt hoffentlich
sobald wie möglich mehr kommt müssen wir
das wasser verfahren kommen
das heißt so schnell zu breit im fuß
geht es sie in den usa und england wird
in supermärkten gamestop beim
vorübergehen
auch da müssen wir uns überlegen ob die
immobilie teststationen haben können
beziehungsweise mobilen stationen die
dann auch an bestimmten ort machen auch
wohin fahren zum beispiel eine
hochschule und dort die studenten impfen
können zum beispiel also ich bin da eher
dafür dass ganze auszahlen die zweite
frage mpk sie haben schon recht das
meinungsbild ist deswegen so
differenziert weil es auch das
meinungsbild der bevölkerung ist die
menschen möchten mehr freiheit aber
gleichzeitig die hohe sicherheit soll
das glaube ich wird immer dich mal
zusammen formulieren einige sagen die
leute haben die schnauze voll
ich habe volles verständnis dass die
menschen und viele menschen einfach müde
ist in ob corona aber die politik darf
nicht müde werden die gefahr
zurückkehren kann entscheiden also ich
habe überhaupt kein problem und es ist
völlig in ordnung wenn manche menschen
abgeschoben school im home-office
zusammen da fällt mir jetzt echt die
decke auf den kopf ja auch ein anderes
angebot oder wenn sie als ist doch
draußen schön und ist die sonne gibt
aber auch den optimismus zu glauben dass
die gefahr geringer wird aber alle
prognosen bislang auch ob der rotation
treten jetzt ein genauso wie fräser
nichts von dem was die experten gesagt
haben
es widerlegt werden jetzt müssen wir
einfach nur kluge schritte definieren
wir brauchen eine für deutschland
einheitliche grundphilosophie klar mit
der regionalen differenzierung das
glaube ich ist selbstverständlich aber
es ist eine philosophie geben
ich verstehe dass in einigen
bundesländer wahlen sind und dass
deswegen der druck ist und dass da auch
zwei bundesländer zb dabei sind die
rheinland pfalz oder auch baden
württemberg die sehr niedrige zahlen
sind nur auf die derzeitige inzidenz
tabelle kann keiner ein festes haus
bauen
das ist dass michael sagte du bist heute
fühlst du dich in deiner tabelle gut und
morgen schnellsten bis zum hotspot es
geht so schnell wir haben im westen die
herausforderung was wie sich das in
frankreich entwickelt frankreich selber
riegel zum teil regionen ab frankreich
selber überlegt wieder kräftigere
schritte zu machen so wir haben jetzt
bei uns die grenzkontrollen zu unseren
partnern in tschechien und auch zu tirol
die ich eine vor ist auch eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme halte von von hoher
relevanz die dann sehen wie sich das
woanders entwickelt deswegen schauen
dass wir vorausschauend kommen aber
nicht einfach entweder wir sehen wir
dann auch aus dem schwarz weiß training
heraus kommen die allen lockern ohne
rücksicht und die anderen quasi sperren
zu ohne weitsicht kunst ist jetzt da ein
kluges öffnungs konzept zu entwickeln
eine öffnung smatax die möglichkeiten
bietet sowohl für vorne zu gehen als
auch wieder zu reagieren und da ist noch
eine menge stück arbeit bis zur mittwoch
und ich glaube dass sie mittwoch wenn
die mpk beginnt um 14 uhr ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass wir um 16 und 17
uhr bereits ein ergebnis haben das wird
am mittwoch eine ein langer tag und ein
langer abend
das ist aber auch notwendig das zu
diskutieren weil wir brauchen jetzt
schon an den rahmen der zweck denn wenn
wir da es am mittwoch einen fehler
machen dann wird vertrauen grundlegend
für spielt und deswegen möchte ich
einfach dass wir uns damit wir die zeit
nehmen und ist klug beraten und nach dem
so viel jetzt auch immer gesagt haben
öffnen öffnen wir beide sind bereit auch
wir wollen so viel freiheit zurückgeben
wie es nur irgendwie geht wir wollen
auch mehr emanzipation der bürger in
dieser cola fast mehr mehr mehr
verantwortung auch zurückgeben
selbstverständlich aber ebenso dass wir
nicht drei wochen später vor einem chaos
und scherben auferstehen das ist uns
alles sind wenn dann ostern völlig
völlig wir bereits in der 3
es sind und angekündigt die öffnungen
komplett wieder anders machen müssen
dann ist es übrigens auch nicht im
interesse der wirtschaft und des handels
in der gast den abschluss macht thilo
alexe sechs sächsische zeitung
ja liebe grüße aus dresden in die runde
an mich interessiert vor allem von herrn
kretschmann aber auch von herrn söder
die frage vor der mpk wie stehen sie zum
thema schule öffnung vielen dank beim
thema schuleröffnung werden wir zu
meiner sich keine großen schritte
erleben können
wir haben grundschulen wir haben
kindergärten
sie haben erlebt wie wir im vogtland
jetzt aus meiner sicht aus wichtigen
gründen dafür gesorgt dass wir das
wieder zurück genommen haben weil wenn
zu viel mobilität ist zeigt sich dass
überall rum
von daher sehe ich dort für die
weiterführenden schulen und die sich
sehr geht derzeit jetzt keine
möglichkeit so bitter wie das ist das
würde ich sehen besteht die chance dann
wenn man mit schnelltests konzepten
weiter kommt dass das nach den
osterferien möglich ist wir sind nicht
komplett gleich beim thema schulen
habt ihr mit anderen ansatz als wir wir
haben da klare grenzziehungen getroffen
auch mit incidents wobei wir da bei der
inzidenz des jetzt sogar noch unterlegen
werden die woche dass wir das ein
bisschen an schule die die zeitachse für
nicht einen tag auf den anderen sondern
auf eine etwas längere planbare sicht
haben können damit man sich auch darauf
einstellen kann
auch da gilt der grundsatz werden wenn
inzidenz sind sehr sehr niedrig sind
dann geht mehr das ist ganz logisch wenn
keine zahlen beider institute
31 stabil 7 89 tage da kann auch denkbar
sein dass da mal aus einem wechsel
unterricht präsenzunterricht wird das
müssen wir einfach schauen und mittwoch
noch mal besprechen
ich plädiere schon dafür dass wir
mittwoch übrigens in der mpk das thema
schule michael weiss jetzt völlig
ausklammern
dann müssen zumindest mal einen gedanken
darüber verlieren schule ist ländersache
aber und es findet daher auch wenig
grenzüberschreitendes stadt nicht
ausgeschlossen aber wenig ja aber so
werden wir uns dann auch mit unseren
grenzen bei dem thema noch mal erhalten
aber sie haben es beim bei der
vorletzten mpk gesehen hat eben der von
mir hoch geschätzte winfried kretschmann
am abend noch erklärt eröffnete die
schule und musste sie dann doch wieder
verschieben man hat einfach die lage an
das ist deswegen es bleibt immer dabei
die daten bestimmen und nicht das
gelegte tat um
vielen dank dann schließen wir die
pressekonferenz schöne grüße nochmal
nach sachsen dankeschön